[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to the iron
lords podcast
for this game called insurmountable
now uh i wanted to tell you all that
uh this game i ended up playing it on my
twitch channel
uh because i had a couple of people in
the channel telling me about it
and wanting to play it so uh this game
was made by
rockbiter games um and
i wasn't 100 sure how i was gonna feel
about it
i myself have uh gone and i've been a
rock climber
uh for uh in my in my past life
many years ago i used to go rock
climbing on a regular basis
and i wanted to see how the
thought process was kind of thrown into
this game now research
insurmountable has cultures a lot of
different
things a lot of them i was not expecting
for them to take and
implement ever as beautifully as they
did
now now remote first start the game
now i'm going to take this you guys as a
person
who knew nothing about the game turned
it on
started playing it and went through it
you then start the game you first start
the game as a
individual who's looking to climb this
mountain and
during this time you are end up going to
pick
uh what type of a skilled climber you
are
which is going to give you you know
either some items to be able to allow
you to climb
the mountain with or it's going to give
you
a different types of
choice uh positive or negative effects
as you are going through this mountain
sure now
mountain when you
[Music]
past that point then end up having to
pick what type of mountain you are going
to climb
and then from there which type of
direction you're going to climb from
when you're going through this you start
off and you're like okay
this doesn't look too bad and then you
end up
going and looking from location to
location
throughout the whole entire grassy area
to pick up items or pick up
uh different types of markers or things
from different parts of the ground where
you're walking around
now once you
the
icy plane let's say you go from your
grass to your rock to your ice
things start changing drastically
snow with you having to move during the
night
all of these things play into different
effects of your character
the night time being cold the the sanity
level of you going
crazy because of you being on this rock
by yourself if you slip and fall you're
taking
you know damage or hurt damage there's
the
the oxygen level once you hit a certain
point
start actually having o2 loss because
you're higher than
you're the air is thinner and it's
harder for you to breathe
now i thought this game was going to
only take me
a couple of hours to get through i was
like oh
piece of cake so we end up
about an hour in i hit the first summit
and i'm like awesome cool boom thumbs up
done not the case what ended up
happening was
you actually then get tasked to go down
the mountain
to camp i think it's the next camp let's
call it
so we end up hiking down the hill we
finally get to the camp
barely alive and i'm like
made it done bubble stage
or over next thing it asks you to do is
ask you to
take another hiking point and i'm like
excuse me
so they ended up to having it to make
you go and hike
to another location to allow you to
continue and at that point i was just
like
mentally i can't handle it my twitch
channel was just like
this is a this is crazy this is awesome
this is so much fun this is cool
so we need you know but we had enough
for like they were even stressed out by
it
so we ended up you know taking a break
and and going back to it
later but the game itself
is beautifully drawn
the movement for the heck the hexagonal
movement around the map done really
really enjoyed it
really liked it the
it changes from day to night
i can't tell you how how amazing i felt
like they were intense means
from those little changes you felt that
there was
a huge huge huge amount of
thought that was put into the game and i
really really did enjoy it
i really want you guys to go and to pick
up this game
it's out on steam uh it's called
insurmountable
all right i it's now though here telling
you
go and get it i you know i know that you
that you probably hear me say that about
many of the games i
that we end up reviewing here but
because
we think that people should be touching
this game
playing it i really really enjoyed it
and i would like to again thank
rockbiter games for giving us this code
i greatly appreciate it
i really love this game and as always
you guys can check me out on twitter uh
sneldo if you're looking for times and
everything
level itself and you can check out
sunday's
the iron lords podcast on youtube check
us out uh greatly appreciate it and
lords of gaming.net
where you're looking for all of your
online gaming check
us out we'll see you soon thank you
skill here which is reduced terrain
on reduced energy costs on all terrains
uh strong energy efficiency on flat
terrain allows to expert
the mountain thoroughly exploring the
mountain for too long threatens your
sanity
night climber specializes in night
climbing gain more experience in the
in events during the night exceptional
bonus when climbing during the night no
bonus during the day
and the night is still dangerous
suitable expert utilizing
i'm sorry i can't read specializing in
utilizing consumables
whenever you use a consumable item you
get some sanity
strong at getting the most out of your
consumable items all bonuses are
dependent on
finding consumable items
[Music]
yeah he's he's out i wonder if it's
because the water is lower
we're picking light step one
all right
oh that's a long walk
no no oh oh can we i did it again
that is like the perfectly placed
location for me to always want to hit
cancel
well that's humorous
so we have to go around this way
to get to there
and then that looks like it's a cave
so we can go stopping huh
this
climbing
i choose the the path and he just goes
i'm gonna fall it's just cruising
i'm really intrigued to see what happens
once you hit ice
no we could speed uh well we have a
sprint button
but it like does a lot of other stuff
that i don't think is necessary
mountain goat standing behind a rock
a and using its head to point and play
in direction you're walking
is it trying to walk does it try to warn
you
ignore it or i hide behind the rock too
high behind the rock walking just a few
feet ahead of you
is a large wild cat
and this is neither you nor the goat
good job goat
always listen to the goat
oh my god oh god
she's so bad you lean against the rock
face you notice a hollow
hollowed
yeah someone has left some provisions
there
i use a branch i push the boulder aside
this we know we lose energy
yeah because you're pushing it or you
use a branch
where's chat with my answers um
uh
i feel like if i i'm gonna push a branch
so
i'm using a branch
oh
we lose nothing and we injure ourselves
fantastic
okay
all right
love you bye okay careful steps
uh spending more time while moving but
dangerous
terrain increase sanity gain
in events uh oh
no no no deep breaths increase maximum
oxygen we need to increase our sanity
in events because i think that is what's
going to be our
problem child temporary debuffs
injured torso uh into 24 hours painful
breathing
this is our traits
our equipment is just the climbing
gloves environment
clear
okay
now start walking back the way we came
see
see what happens i think this is a camp
out thing
which would be pretty cool i really
would like to see what happens when we
do hit these types of points
um but we're gonna we're gonna start
walking up the mountain-ish
i feel like there's a certain thing you
have to like gain certain xp
while leveling up
you enter a cave it's dry and sheltered
from the wind
at the rear of the cave you notice a
shimmer
faint shimmer of light i lie down and
sleep
i follow the light i leave the cave
uh i follow the light
it's covered for 100 fireflies which are
fascinating
return to the cave entrance
uh i mean we can lay down sleep
but we still have a lot of energy i
don't want to lay down sleep
i'm gonna leave the cave
oh that was nice of him i'll have to
i'll message him later
alright so now we're gonna go
oh that's a long hike
now is it easier
oh no that's probably our
our fastest way to go
we really can't see any anywhere else
i thought there was a like oh there was
a cave over there
i was doing a thing okay our body
temperature is going up
our sanity is going down our energy is
going down
oxygen's going down and we are now in
night time
oh boy cans thumb with smoke rises
up into the sky in front of you you turn
around a corner
the wall of the cliff and discover a
campfire
flames already licking the sides of the
cans placed around it
you stamp on the fire to put it out you
collect snow and put out the fire
what should we do i think we're gonna
collect snow and stamp out the fire
oh we get a can of food that way
oh we're taking that bad boy
look at that we can kind of move
everything around so we have a tent that
we can use to rest at any time
we have two cans of food for energy
which is baller
uh and there are climbing gloves okay
confirm
see there's something over here too
looks like a
stop for a second there so i see
something here
go up here i wonder if we should go over
there
down there it seems like there's another
oh there's a treasure over there too
are we exploring too much or too little
i've yet to figure it out
a golden eagle subtly lands in front of
you it's winds carrying
it's majestically to the ground
fascinating
that's it you watch it and it watches
you unafraid you cannot explain it but
the encounter feels majestic
fully wrapped to the moment you regain
sanity or warmth
i'm thinking sanity
i feel like sanity is going to be harder
for you to get or get back
and i think that once the daytime
hits we will get our warmth
back
and our oxygen is being used because it
is cold out
i also feel like i should be trying to
get as much
possible levels and situational things
down on this lower tier of the
[Music]
mountain because once we get higher up
the mountain
we just blaze we just like blaze up the
[Music]
mountain
[Music]
however you know it's a small smell
all the smell okay
turn to the cave entrance
lie down sleep
a long sleep will give us
full energy how long is long sleeve
oh let us take a brief
sleep we'll get our temperature back our
energy back oxygen back and we'll get
some time back
because we'll be during the daytime it's
storming
all right fantastic okay
uh reduces sanity loss in events
consumable expert which we've had before
and night climber
so we kind of know briefly what these
two are our reduced saturday loss in
events
strong at getting the most out of the
events no bonus outside of the events
um symbol expert is pretty nice
because we'll have the ability to
[Music]
oh thanks for telling me hon my wife
just told me she took the guinea pig
upstairs with her
all right so this will give us a little
bit of sanity but not a lot
is that sanity going to really affect us
long term this i think will affect us
more
long-term game or experience and nights
during events at night
i think robust mind will be better for
us
today oh
oh boy oh boy oh whoa
like we can barely see anything
all right see the body temperature is
going up as i expected
because it is during the daytime which
is nice
so we'll we will be able to get our body
temperature back during the day
we're going to lose a little more sanity
because it's of this
snowy weather
not too bad the rest of stuff is not too
bad
over here seems like an interesting but
not my
type of game no like um
there was uh this game is very similar
to like you know one of those question
builder type games
are you skimmer in an intent there's
nobody in sight but the embers of the
fire pits are still glowing
the camp is obviously being used by
someone you could have valuable
items search the camp
or continue your journey
um
i am not going to do anything to that
person's tent
arma wasn't there another thing over
here
oh it's all over there i mean that's a
hike
uh all right just do it
oh there's a space bar which speeds up
the guy from right there speaks of the
guy running
okay hey liv how you doing good
good evening it's like a new version of
oregon trail without the nostalgia i
have for that game
ah no raid tonight no no live
you stand under the skeleton of old
trees and exposed roots from
from a from a hollow
seems to lead deep into the earth
someone has set traps in front of you
maybe they hid
something in the hole
i'm not chancing that
take some damage watch all right
all that says it's gonna turn into night
like i said liv i will not want to end
up giving this uh you know a good
try they wanted us to take a look at the
game play for a little bit so i said why
why not so i figured we'll uh we'll play
for a little bit
all right i
don't see anything right here
um
up there is the mount where we gotta go
i guess we can go this way i will say
the graphics and the effects are pretty
damn good
we'll do this event and there's a cave
there is over
a chest that is almost completely buried
in the snow
dig it out we'll take energy
uh all right do it
we find a warm cap
it's pretty nice all right here's a cave
so we're gonna go into the cave anyway
we're gonna take a quick little
naparooni or we could take a long nap
uh into the darkness uh follow
use a torch which we don't have a step
into the darkness
turn around okay uh lie down
sleep we get uh we're gonna need a lot
of energy back
so
we're gonna that's 10
points we're gonna get that we're gonna
get that um
or do we do a brief sleep find another
cave
and then sleep it out
i think that's what we're gonna have to
do we're gonna have to find another
place hopefully the storm is gone ah the
storm is gone
beautiful all right so we can kind of
look around a little better
now
all right
that is actually not too bad
or we go this way
we get a couple other things oh and
there's another one over there
hmm
this is that breaking point of snow also
i think we're just gonna go this way
with it
because we're gonna almost be out of
energy if we don't
we don't do it this is what i wanted to
see these long
climbs what they would end up doing
oh just a regular climb okay
what will this give us here
but but there's no soul around
fighting the icy wind for survival
watching the fire just around
gain energy
so we wanted all this cave over there
beautiful all right
oh my god we can't
go this way
oh my god we gotta do like a whole loop
around
oh boy
we are gonna run out of energy if we go
that way
oh oh boy
all right um
[Music]
well that is no good
we're gonna have to go this way
pray that it has something to do with
energy
or we're just gonna have to eat a can of
food
can of food will work also we're gonna
go into the night time too
so we need to get into that cave
go this way first
thanks marsh i need some uh cast bars
if only
so mr champs
um you pull out a crate and it turns out
to be empty how disappointing
dammits
i know we need more weak horrors in this
in this game
it's a very different type of game than
what we're used to playing
it's an event
nearby the camp there are vacuum
flasks filled with tea you could
take the time to search the tent
uh take a quick look around us
thoroughly i thoroughly
filled with tea will give us body
temperature
some xp
um
we might have to start drinking some
stuff and doing some things here
we are getting low on energy
oh there's two camping areas oh it's
beautiful
and see that one uh you hear a
soft squeaking coming from somewhere
take a look around
and discover a mountain hair cowering
inside a rockfisher
it's true it trembles as you approach it
but just not try to flee you suspect i
might be injured
uh i'm just gonna continue my journey
there's no way in hell i'm gonna hurt
that animal
that is us running out of energy getting
there
we can get there
and not run out of energy
uh ksm feels amazing i'm so happy that i
was able
to finally complete it like
it it feels like night and day
difference for me
so i am very very happy that we were
able
to complete it i'm very happy
cave all the smell
get some xp for following the smell
which is pretty normal in life you know
lie down sleep we're taking a long nap
because we need energy and warmth
we start boom
yep yep i got it all right there's
another cave down there and there's this
over here
we're gonna we're gonna go do both of
those
um
begins the effects of cold weather
uh enthusiasm when you reach a pci you
gain energy
let's take enthusiasm first
because we energy seems to be a
never-ending issue
with us
they are a crutch
scream runs the air you stop a broken
list on the screen
it's followed by a snarl you cautiously
creep towards the stars
panda rock you see a hunter armed with a
knife locked in a struggle with a cougar
his face is streaked with blood
the hunter's pack is lying on the ground
nearby you could grab
it and he will never see you
help the hunter
take the pack continue the journey
what do you think will be the optimal
thing here
helping the hunter or ignoring them and
taking the pack
chat what do you think i should do do
you think i should help the hunter and
almost use all of our energy
ignore him and just leave or just take
his backpack
help the hunterd that's how i kind of
feel
all right let's see what happens
you tackle the animal knocking away from
the hunter the cougar is
so shocked that scampers away yelping
the hunter
is just as a full mocks and he be
against rummaging through his pack
mumbling something ineligible
it seems that the seems as
though he wants to reward you for saving
him
his body is flocked with endorphins
you wonder if a parley gift might dampen
your flusher victory
uh you accept the gift which is hot tea
which we already have two
of and xp or
i thank him but decline the gift which
will give us good
consciousness will give us more sanity
while moving and 50
insanity gains for events we're gonna
thank him
and decline the gifts
just pretty dang nice
we are gonna sleep and get some energy
back
there's a cave all the light
[Music]
some sanity fly down to sleep we're
taking a long nap again
through most of nightfall
which is good so we can get our
heat back and get some energy back which
is really really nice
all right
there's no way for us to get over there
correct
we will run out of energy because
apparently
that takes way too much
to do um
unless
there is a simpler path
[Music]
um
like i feel like oh it's because that
that heavy climb look at that heavy
climb that heavy climb right there
takes so much energy which means the
lesser the climbs
the less energy it's gonna take
so
um
going backwards
might be the safest way to go
because we are going to essentially
have less increased heights
to get over or are we just totally effed
no we can do this
that's way better than the other way
then going straight up that way
it just takes us a little more time
oxygen is not in use because we don't
have any broken ribs or anything our
temperature is
increasing just good
there's a place to nap there i don't
think we're gonna be able to make it
there
oh look at this
we could
we could but it'll be dangerous
can't go that way it looks like we can't
go that way the only way to do this
would be to do a heavy hike
directly up here to here
and that will take most of our energy if
we do that
uh
man i can't believe how big this place
is
now we could do this hike
and then do we have enough to hike back
we do
um
or do we have enough to hike up to there
then to there we do
this is going to be a huge hike
huge hike
and look at which energy we're going to
end up with
we're going to end up with like five
energy
let's hope we get some good luck here
oh and there's another thing there
all those like equipment stuff down
there too damn
[Music]
you keep listening the music seems to be
coming from inside the mountain
could be yet another legacy of the
occupier
or maybe it's oranges of mystery
whatever makes you smile
we get sanity and xp
which is fine all right
this is gonna be difficult
this is the difficult part of this hike
right here
apparently this is all rocky
you're a couple of loose stones rolling
down the mountain one of them hits you
in the torso
oh a little bit of xh xp
damage it's okay we got this we got this
all right this is one of the shrines
sanity or warmth
we're gonna take sanity
all right went to the cave
we're gonna lie down and sleep a long
sleep for most of the night time
which is good because we're keeping our
warmth
and we're getting energy
all right so now we have to go up
that way
oh oh my
might actually be the easiest way to do
it
these boards are long
i never i never thought it was going to
be this long
to be able to get all the way up there
mean we still have a tent which
still has three uses oh great stormy
great
oh there's another cave here
um
see how this goes
that's looking believe i took health
damage
what it is is snow and several tents not
far away
we set up a care camp here you call out
but no answer
oh okay
chat i need some need some need some
input okay uh
your breath is taken away towering in
front of you
on the slopes are blizzard illusory
shaped masses of
ice and snow and
several tents not far away who could set
up of
this these this camp here you call out
but no
answers
do i approach the camp check
the slope or go to the the first tents
what do you think i should do here
approach the camp check the slope
or go to the tents you think i should
approach the camp
all right i'm trusting you you slowly
approach the camp the ice crunches
beneath your boots
every step could be your last you
but you choose you close your eyes
finally you reach your goal
the camp is abandoned with not a soul in
sight
they surely left long ago you rummage
through the things that they left behind
and find some equipment
at least your efforts were not in vain
so we get warmth sanity xp
we lose a little time and we get snow
boots
we leveled up okay
uh
liv that was an amazing call
i'm gonna give you a clap some claps
there uh
here we're going to take inner fire
uh this is going to allow us to gain
more body temperature per hour when
moving
that's going to be good long term
all right let us continue with our route
here
the shrine
right what do we take sanity or energy
we
take energy
saturn is pretty good backpack you find
a pack-back concealed under a layer of
snow
blueprints lead away from the spot in a
zigzag pattern
and disappear behind a rock follow the
tracks
search the backpack continue the journey
um do we follow the tracks
which will use energy or search the
backpack which will give us
that
i'm thinking we search for tracks
because we're going to be going
we're going to be getting to a cave
really really soon and we can gain back
our energy
anyway so let's
follow the tracks you grab the backpack
and follow the tracks
you spot a tent sheltered beneath
from the wind beneath two sheer rock
faces you can hear loud snoring coming
from inside and cautiously approximately
suddenly
a beard-eyed haggard face pops up
pops out of the tent flap
snower smiles at you as they spot the
backpack in your outreach
hand uh you know that was pretty amazing
what do we get the stranger takes the
backpack and reaches inside they roams
around and pull out a can of food
which they offer to you you aren't sure
if you should accept the gift after all
the stranger is
thin as a rail and probably needs the
food more than you
except the food
or thank him but decline
the food is gonna give us energy which i
feel like we're gonna need
a lot more when we go up the
um up the mountain
sanity i think we're it's gonna you know
we've been doing pretty good and not
losing any
yeah i'm thinking the same thing uh
we're gonna thank him for the gift but
decline
decline taking it because we still have
two cans of food
we're in a cave
we get our sanity back at some xp
or 100 100 lie down for sleep
we're going to take a quick we can take
a quick brief nap
or a long nap if we take the long
nap it's going to benefit us more
because we're going to be sleeping more
in the darkness
so we're going to be traveling less at
night
and it's harder for us to kind of see
anything at night
um
as you can see we really can't see much
so if we end up doing a little bit of a
search here and there
stop
go this way instead
uh
search the tents
we find one bottled oxygen tank
boom
that was a find man
and we're out of the freaking s no
all right
all right let's see here
this is flatter like you could like go
balls to the walls and go like
right up right here
or we can kind of play it on the safer
side
no definitely not that way
like that we're gonna use less
energy that way and then we can climb up
this
let's go like that it's gonna use more
time
but it's gonna be more efficient for us
there's a cave up there too which is
gonna be good
uh death zone is 600 meters
and that's when we start losing oxygen
um
i want to look at our inventory
rough stone twist our ankle
loss of energy on terrain well son of a
bee
uh director crypto review
do we okay you trip and bend your knee
cursing up a storm you kick the rock you
tripped over
revealing a crack in the ground it's
seeing
it seems as though someone has used the
crack
to hide their possessions
examine it or make the crack
bigger
uh the frozen earth has been kind to it
you skim the handwritten note where they
pinned
by another mountaineer for over five
five figure
50 years ago before the island's
extinction of the la
someone has said some of the stash
provisions here
crampons
these go on boots
these are better for ice
like this is snow this is ice
so we are
in better conditions i would guess you
could say
or can we go this way
or this way
oh there's a thing over there too
uh
i'm trying to
those balls to the wall kicking the gear
that's how people
die man i'm not going balls to the walls
i'm just go i'm going to move a little
quicker than normal though
but we're going to hit nightfall very
very shortly we're going to hit this
then hopefully we'll hit that it looks
like we're doing more
around the corner than i was expecting
don't hurt yourself
this is one of those ones that could
hurt yet uh we gotta go over it twice
oh we can gain health or energy let's
gain health
you're not participating feel holy
we gain health so we're almost back at
full health
that was fantastic and we just hurt
ourselves
for two just just exactly what we got
back from the shrine
fantastic
observed chest behind the ledge open and
find some
herbs sanity and health
some pot moon herbs
oh no i i am going to
do that sir
i think we're gonna start hustling very
very soon
because i think we we're doing pretty
good i feel like we're doing pretty good
i'll increase maximum energy whenever
you reach a poe
gain more energy
[Music]
or maximum energy this will continuously
give us
energy this will give us an overall
energy
this is going to give us more over time
i feel like
all right so this is the question we got
to ask ourselves
do we go this way which we're going to
be doing steep climbs
and we're going to be going through ice
and stuff
oh and then we're and we're going to get
into the death zone which we're gonna
require is to have oxygen or
do we go this way
i wanna live a little dangerous right
now
let's go a little dangerous i'm doing
this for you liv
all right doing this for you right now
all right just one more throne button
okay this is gonna require us to use
10.2
10.3
8.5
11.9
so we're gonna go this way
that's why i just didn't up and get rid
of it oh great
while climbing while climbing next to a
flat crevasse you lose your footing and
start to slide down
after a few feet you managed to catch
yourself
i quickly pull myself up two slopes
or i carefully let myself slide down the
slopes
one i'm gonna lose energy the other i'm
going to lose
heat
i feel like losing heat is going to be
better for us
we would have gone with the energy
because it's almost night but the
closest cave is all the way up here
so what we're gonna have to do is um
we're gonna i'm gonna go over here
get this poi and then we're gonna take
the poi and then we're gonna go up to
the cave
and then sleep and that's we're pretty
close
right now to tonight fall when we get to
the other spot it'll be nightfall
so we'll sleep it out and when we sleep
it out we're going to get temperature
and energy back no matter what
so we'll get them both
those several spiders vanish into a hole
in the ground
you bend over to inspect the hole it
looks like there's something hidden
there
reach into the hole or continue
reach into the hole
find something soft a cloth bag you pull
it out and discover equipment inside
no climbing axe yes
amazing amazing find
that was amazing balls
look how much it's almost using no
energy now
uh exchange is your boots
we're hitting the death zone the air is
getting thin
and you breathe your breath is heavy you
have entered the death zone you pause
ramona to prepare for a difficult
path towards the summit
so there there are
multiple things you can do at this point
it looks like once you hit the death
zone which is kind of interesting
so the air is getting thin and you
breathe you breath is heavy
so you enter the death zone and you
pause for a moment while you're looking
for it so you can ascend quickly
which will half all terrain costs but it
ends in eight hours
you take it slow which ends in 24
and you gain oxygen
per hour when moving
one is only eight hours and we're going
to be sleeping for part of those eight
hours
anyway so i'm gonna say we're gonna take
it slow
oh you lose oxygen while sleeping
that is unreal all right i didn't
realize that
thankfully we have the air
all right so we're gonna have to start
holding ass to the top
seems like
uh what do i have on for i have the
we do have the ability to stop
at some points
um
we're gonna have to try to stay as flat
as possible
we can try to straight up just join
ourselves straight up here
i don't know how efficient that's gonna
be there's another cave on the right
full but not far you land at the bottom
of a flat
snowy crevasse
oof
encounter a mountaineer sitting
listening
on the night to ground it does not seem
to notice you
oh you encourage the mountaineer to
stand up
it's gonna use a lot of our oxygen and
our temperature
if i continue to walk i lose some sanity
i
there's no way in hell i'm giving him an
oxygen bottle
i think we're gonna need our oxygen
what do you what do you think we should
do encourage them
walk away from them or give him an
oxygen bottle
i mean we could encourage them which is
only going to take time and oxygen
[Music]
we have the oxygen bottle to give us
oxygen back and we have the thermoses to
give us
temperature all right we'll encourage
him
the mountaineer remains seated and it
won't be moved
all right man your
deal so now our question what do we do
do we go
[Music]
i'm just curious how much energy would
it take
would it take for us to go straight up
take a decent amount of energy
to just eat straight up the wall
all right we're just going straight up
the wall we're doing it
we're getting our temperature back
because we're moving too
the oxygen level is kind of crazy but
i think it's also because we have
preserve your breath on
these are all not too good spots
an old woman sits in front of a crooked
house she
wears a friendly tooth to smile and
motions you to sit down with her
to recharge her [ __ ] you do as she
suggests
and regain warmth or health
um
what do you think what do you think liv
should i
regain warmth or health right now
yeah that's what i'm kind of thinking
i'm curious what will happen if i just
click the top
oh we would run out of energy
all right
looks like there's an easier climb up
the back
then the front
yeah it is there's an easier climb up
the front than the back
oh this gives us 45 oxygen
i'm not sure
oh there's a cave here too
you touch through a slope pile tie and
snow you see
deeper drift away you suddenly your boot
meets resistance
you push the snow aside exposing a metal
surface with colored markings
on it created but still
an identif uh identifiable there is no
doubt about it you found a wig of a
downed
airplane dig deeper
examine the wing or continue journey
dig deeper it's gonna use a bunch of our
energy i guess it's okay because we're
gonna sleep
and then we're gonna we're gonna have to
sleep use o2 and then we're just gonna
have to whole ass up top
and then eat food or whatever we need
for energy
you're gross in the work another corner
of your eye you spot a
building cloud of snow coming towards
you you quickly dive into a recess of
rocks seconds later
a ton of snow and ice come through
tunneling down
above you you are plunged into darkness
the
the cold seeps into your bones gas for
air slowly you
you start to dig and you burst through
the snow
into your lungs so we lost even more
energy and temperature
like gain xp well that is not
bueno
davey good evening to you sir how are
you uh you entered the cave
we are going to sleep and lie down
you're taking a long sleep
this is going to be crazy because we are
going to be
nightfall i'm using our oxygen
yes i'm using oxygen
all right now it's time we're going to
try to go up
all the way
doing it we're gonna consume we're gonna
use food consumption
apparently there are better ways to do
this than allowing the auto
director to go
northern lights what a sight sanity and
xp
we gain a little energy from it
highly increases sanity gains and events
weakens the effects of cold weather
slight reduces
sanity laws and events
uh we can cause cold
all right we're gonna eat some food
yes we need some more food
yes we're gonna take our body
temperature up yes
please
all right
go to the summit
i hope they don't ask us to go down now
your heart feels light and full of joy
as you stand it on
the summit the hardships of the climb
are already forgotten you savor the
moment
[Music]
you